où nous donne la réponse vous me donnez
là attention première réponse derrière
montiel
la réponse est derrière montiel qu'est
ce qui m'arrivera jamais
[Applaudissements]
où
se trouve la carrière de la carrière de
bernard montiel derrière où
se trouve en tant qu'arrière
non c'est pas que ça allait derrière
montiel intérieur officiels derrière mon
pied par sa voix derrière montier oui
oui
selon un dernier sondage ils se trouvent
benjamin castaldi oui
c'est vite l'heure est grave je voulais
pas le dire ce soir j'ai dit alors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez lors de
séquences est bon on a vu sur ce match
là c'est quoi cette fiche alors que je
dévoile ce placement
est moins populaire que bernard session
alors je vais vous montrer ce classement
qui m'arrivait mais qui vient d'où
beaucoup de mal c'est un sondage selon
les règles de l'art auprès de 1000
personnes représentatives de la france
et lui raconte alors tout un
sondage qui a été fait sur twitter pour
savoir quand il est le meilleur
animateur de ces huit mois la part 50
ans qui avoue en numéro 1 90% bazire
doit juste moi c'est pas ça qu'on
retient c'est que bernard montiel arrive
en deuxième position nord est et à boé
wii est devant vous et regardez vous
avez fait je vois pas l'écran là vous
êtes devant à 21 et 8 % 21 par rapport à
vous c'est dingue bas c'est déjà
beaucoup
avec eux j'ai écouté
déjà très étonné on met des mots c'était
que les garçons accord c'est propre et
maintenant qu'est ce que vous en savez c
3po missiles sur patins oui mais
l'animateur l'amitié et petits coups
comme
les rayer plus comblé que c'est
désormais
frappe aussi battu au dax a pas vraiment
à ses frais de bouche et je peux parler
j'ai très touchée je remercie le public
à voter non s'en fout ensemble et on
s'en fout de savoir mais je suis très
touchée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et voudrait renverser les huit pour cent
des gens qui ont voté pour moi
attention c'est drôle réponse piquer la
place d'un chroniqueur a piqué la plage
après la place d'un chroniqueur ne
chroniqueuse mais quelle est la question
telle est la question c'est oui que le
faire amender une petit les miss france
actuelle a alors elle peut pas elle n'a
pas dit ça touré et pourrait faire
piquer la place d'un conducteur rêve là
d'affaires amandine petit la miss france
actuelle à l'aimer l'adorent j'ai fait
on a fait fait d'ailleurs à prendre ou à
laisser ensemble à l'arrêt elle est
extrêmement sympathique elle joue jeux
et regarder ce qu'elle a dit au micro de
jordan de luxe ça sent ça sent la ronde
nouvelles recrues c'est sympa c'est le
11 décembre je pense qu'à la rentrée des
vacances ce sera ça ferai avec plaisir
on l'accueillera guillaume genton qui
vont avec saisir dans l'accueil
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
2faire touche pas à mon poste j'ai
participé à tpm pesaro dépistage
obligatoire de miss france on y
participe et c'était très sympa d'accord
c'est très sympathique si cyril vous
proposer les chroniqueuses ça pourrait
vous de tenter ça pourrait ça pourrait
être quelque chose d'intéressant après
dans l'absolu j'ai beaucoup apprécié
être à la radio ouais donc quitte à être
chroniqueuse je pense que dans
l'immédiat je serai peut-être plutôt
chroniqueuse à la radio pour commencer
je serais cru à tort elle est très
sympathique elle prévoit l'émission y'a
pas beaucoup monsieur
[Rires]
labeaume attend des prés salés françois
tient une fraîcheur blecher single toi
t'as chewing gum machine depuis des
années non mais c'est bon arrêtés n'ont
jamais brillé pour tuer pour aimer nos
pieds pourquoi bon bah très bien voilà
bien les mecs prépa de tous est pur il
va avoir des places on tourne on tourne
pas on tourne pas bons on éliminera des
gens
[Rires]
nikos est plus là
il est là nicolas il est donné
sans rigoler au son âme et la ribambelle
à nicolas
[Musique]
[Rires]
infinitésimale
lui tonus
radius c'est toi
la réponse est malade malade l'aréna les
terres non mais tu te plaît ma gueule et
faire poser une question dans quel état
est la reine d'angleterre malade malade
et lait bio dans quel état est la reine
d'angleterre malades oui bon pour vous
vous savez la reine elizabeth ii la
reine quoi mais de très belles et les
n est pas très bien où en sont nos
relais sais pas où frêche l'a fait pour
faire un paddle ce week end m à
10h15 foule
dans la nuit du mercredi 20 au jeudi fo
tient elle avait passé la nuit à
l'hôpital privé edward seven et de
recettes derrière dans un communiqué
elle a annoncé qu'elle ne se rendrait
pas à la coop 26 il y avait une grosse
soirée
du 31 octobre au 12 novembre à glasgow 1
elle sera absente pour des raisons de
santé micheline alors comment va-t-elle
faut-il s'attendre au pire pour elle bat
ye bientôt y avoir un roi d'angleterre
parce que ce sera un roi d'angleterre un
petit récap et bertrand deckers y sera
avec nada cotillard c'est le spécialiste
de la royauté spécialiste de la
monarchie il est là je vois frère blake
ben je le vois pas mes envies
[Rires]
il ya une semaine toute l'angleterre
ôter son souffle alors que la reine
elizabeth ii passé la nuit à l'hôpital
petite frayeur après l'hospitalisation 7
me de la reine d'angleterre la reine
d'angleterre a passé une nuit à
l'hôpital la reine elizabeth ii a passé
la nuit dernière à l'hôpital
au final un léger coup de fatigue pour
la dame de 95 ans et un retour au
château de windsor le lendemain midi
pour prendre un peu de repos elle est
rentrée au château de windsor hier à
midi elles gardent bon moral pourtant
hier c'est le palais de buckingham qui a
annoncé sur conseil de son médecin que
la souveraine ne pourraient pas se
rendre à la conférence internationale
sur le climat le premier devoir en moi
sa majesté déçu de ne pas pouvoir
assister à la réception mais elle
s'adressera aux délégués réunis par le
biais d'un message vidéo enregistré une
déclaration qui a de quoi inquiéter un
peu plus les britanniques alors faut-il
s'inquiéter de l'état de santé
d'elizabeth ii
et bertrand est avec nous bertrand
deckers un salon bertrand ça va merci ça
fait plaisir de voir des branches
les spéciales de la monarchie
avec elisabeth que moi je t'en fait
inquiète pourquoi il était hospitalisé
bah vous savez isabelle
elizabeth ii tout ce set et j'ai envie
de dire et le jeu entier s'enrhume parce
qu'il n'ya pas grand chose quand mawet à
c'est vraiment une tempête dans un verre
d'eau et merci aux tabloïds que l'on
connaît parfaitement c'est à dire que
mardi dernier grande soirée au château
de windsor elizabeth ii reçoit entre
autres bill gates junkie et rire pour
une grande réception et après le gars
que tu as inventé le
cadre des mousses à l'issue de la
réception elle se dit encore un peu mal
un peu souffrant dès le lendemain en
effet est là on constate elle a le nez
qui fuit une équipe
mais tant qu'à l'appel
à la bndes et qui fut la reine
donc sans l'aide et hors scène c'est à
dire moi je vole à renata de la
jeter dehors machinerie du stent nana
ici voilà je fais quoi là je te dis et
donc ouais donc à la vie de la nation
donc sans mal car en chef à 8 massa qui
est vraiment à la tête de ce qu'on
appelle la royale médical bubble il ya
quatre médecins en permanence de chevet
d'elizabeth ii et oui on est le chef
adacore d'ailleurs été fait sir
décide de l'envoyer à l'hôpital le king
edward vii qui est l'hôpital royal pour
des examens approfondis elle y passera
la nuit et on en sauve si elle avait le
nez qui coule et bakar ce qu'elle se
sentait pas bien la 95e je vous rappelle
quand même qu en angleterre le taux de
coronavirus
considérable
dont il se méfie coulvain peu fatigué il
en profite il lui demande de passer une
nuit à l'hôpital et il en profite pour
faire un check up complet en ressort de
ce check-up deux choses assez
particulière la première on demande à
rennes de se reposer beaucoup de lever
fortement le pied mais encore
et surtout un but surtout
merci le sun c'est le sun qui nous donne
cette information on lui demande de
diminuer fortement sa consommation
d'alcool non
j'aurais vivaqua bah disons que lisa
métal est anglaise et comme tous les
débats
surtout le jeans alors s est inquiétée
ce volet là alors c'est vous prenez une
dose de jean dans le même verre vous
versez 2 doses de du bonnet le du bonnet
c'est un vernis français d'ailleurs
cocorico en quelque sorte d'argument
utilité deux glaçons attention qu'on les
glaçons packard est assez supporte pas
ce qui est public alors furieux glace
son combat va présenter
la détention tout ce qui est public la
réelle des tests auxquels son
anniversaire tu l'as far rubik's cube
est on voit dans les vieux quoi l'armé
fatale des tests est donc là il n'y a
pas péril en la demeure elle va sortir
qu'on les sauve elle
l'a déjà dit à la fin des genêts et elle
elle se fait essentiellement du
télétravail l'entente qui me fascine
c'est la voix de maxime gainey avec un
accent belge
c'est très beau
elle fait du télétravail ne peut
participer à la corvée du télétravail
elle reçoit les gens par vidéo vidéo
conférence en quelques ça travaille
encore à 89 oui c'est beau ce que l'on
peut peut-être dire pourquoi est ce que
les médecins prennent autant de
précautions celle que vous l'avez dire à
la 95 mais surtout surtout l'année qui
s'annonce va être très difficile celle
qui vient de s'écouler a été très
éprouvant mais il a perdu rédigé en juin
toute l'angleterre a déjà décrété une
semaine entière de congé pourquoi parce
que il y avait deux fête ses 70 ans de
rêve elle devient historiquement la
monarque qui a été sur le trône depuis
le plus longtemps le budget alloué est
que le sale et les windsor redoutent ce
moment pourquoi toute petite parenthèse
2002 c'est son jubilé d'or en un mois
d'intervalle elle va perdre ça sort
tenté mais et sa mère queen mum salon
n'a selon elle enterre les deux femmes
les plus importantes de sa ville il dix
ans plus tard 2012 jubilé de diamant il
remonte la tamise dans une grande parade
navale tous les windsor ont pris place à
bord d'une chaloupe à côté d'elle elle a
le prince philip il tombe des trombes
d'eau sur londres il reste stoïque en
fallut en la foule pendant deux heures
35 très précisément et le lendemain le
prince philippe doit être hospitalisé il
fait une infection urinaire à partir de
ce moment là que les problèmes de santé
du prince philip non non c'est donc 2011
2012 2020 tu vois la double échéance de
joinville afin qu'ils la fassent pas
t'en fous tu vas pas faite sous cloche à
cagliari après faut pas être permis de
20 à la place
lui succède à pascal a permis de faire
mon fils la main en angleterre nous
avions la fin on n'avance plus et où ils
ne payent tout cela c'est scier le
j'espère pas parce que j'adore la reine
elizabeth ii j'ai eu l'occasion de la
rencontrer plusieurs fois
si malheureusement il sera sans drame un
jour
c'est william non sacha
de peut-être il pourrait abdiqué pour
laisser directement la place
il a attendu pendant des années j'étais
plus de ça fait 60 à son charme annonce
est l'héritier le plus préparé du globe
alors il y aura un côté psy coup là
qu'ils annoncent aujourd'hui la tension
14 ans que 585 parce que même lui baril
pourrait rester à ce niveau là ça va
tomber comme des mouches
tout comme
ça
scénarisée ning premier réclamant la
portera tenait le nom de red le titre de
reine puisque ce serait un petit peu en
outrage qui se réfère à dylan qui ça
aurait dû revenir la prochaine grande
reine ce sera catherine la reine
catherine ses salles à la 4ème et
devient une histoire autour de la can
ça va être la prochaine vague du béni et
les tabloïds ont fait toute une histoire
à propos de la can légalement
d'elisabeth 2 oui oui pourquoi la fée la
coupe d'afrique des nations
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour le cadre
le 12 juin dernier pour un office
religieux une vraie kahn et elle
apparaît avec une canne en effet depuis
2004 elle en avril au 8 mai 2000 par la
jamaïque 1 suite à une intervention à la
hanche mais surtout surtout bien plus
que la can ce qui nous interpelle les
spécialistes royaux c'est que pour la
toute première fois elle ne passe pas
par le fameux porsche sculptés en pierre
que vous voyez de l'abbaye de
westminster c'est par ce porche sculpté
techniquement que passent tous les croix
dans la terre c'est l'entrée en barrois
les patients elle va passer par une
petite porte latérale comme vous ou que
les oies pourquoi vous y aller par une
toute petite porte latérale et ça pour
elizabeth ii c'est quand même quelque
chose a devancé rapport
forme voilà
on peut tracer en quelque sorte au 12
juin dernier les premiers signes de
cette fatigue qui peut-on commence à
saxon il a des raisons de s'inquiéter ou
pas du tout parce qu on est quand même
sur le fait renoncer à l'heure actuelle
elle est haché à les fatiguer comme une
dame de 86 ans et il n'y a pas de voie
là et d'objets particulière de bronze
mais oui c'est son fils ou sexuelles au
final qui maintenant sont ennuyés aux
états unis ce cas là aussi à gérer ouais
c'est un bordel wes qu'elle elle
pourrait abdiqué non et ce décor comme
dirait director genou peut être oui si
ça va la vie alors tout dit et elle le
fait déjà passer de plus en plus de
dossiers à charrat les chars ni les
graphies d'ailleurs ces huit là
comme ça c'est génial pour charline
écologie et de la première
celle de son père
notre auto là le coach qui me suis là
je pense que c'est il va prendre une
cage ne sont plus importantes d'après
les tabloïds il paraît qu'il n'a pas la
cote avec les anglais que ce serait il
préférait william bill et moi c'est vrai
ça va il faut succéder à elisabeth john
thain incroyable elle est déjà une icône
mais jean vilar est mortelle il y
appellera une immortelle et william à
une très belle popularité surtout
qu'elle est en réalité surtout catherine
il est vraiment entre les deux ça va
être un règne de passation vraiment un
pont qui va être jetés en descente ce
règne incroyable et le futur grand quoi
qui sera william je pense d'accord est
donc là c'est ça ouais donc la
transition
charles zech
très bien franchement donc c'était donc
un jour ils quittent kate middleton raja
famille adore kate middleton ah ouais la
dernière apparition un peu et perd
glamour de quêtes on est à la première
de james bond
elle va oui james bond que chief manneh
est alors avec ce titre incroyable quand
même la mort peut bien à temps le titre
du nouveau film c'est un clin d'oeil
direct à elizabeth ii sur socket voix en
vitrine une robe qui lui plaît allez
couleur or et elle va aller jusqu'à
faire ajouter une petite capitelles va
faire rené qui est exactement de la même
tâté du même hors tout cela est
parfaitement étudiée elle gravit les
marches elle se retourne elle sait que
toutes les caméras sont là et a au
moment où les tirs au but mais en petit
ventre
james bond en personne dira je ne suis
moi qu'au service de sa majesté
daniel craig et du web it sur la vidéo
il est allé à une grande réussite huawei
très fringant et toi tu as l'impression
que tu es très fan de kate middleton ils
deviennent quoi les appelle
ils sont toujours aux états unis a donc
il suffit nice est coupée en tournée de
flemme là mêmes qui les habite et
malades ils reviennent pas ben non pour
l'instant mais vous savez elle n'est pas
officiellement malade à le communiqué
cool et elle est fatiguée dont ils ne
sont pas encore revenus et il paraît que
harry appelle son père tout le temps
pour demander des sous et récurrents
problèmes d'argent c'est vrai a rien
promis les frères il n'a pas pris trop
de barracuda green si c'est énorme il a
couvert un avait vu de train de oui si
c'est elle en effet pour dépenser les 30
millions tu n'as pas ça va très vite à
un bus le train dans sa
vocation c'est bon quoi comment ça se
fait qu'on me la came to lose weight
suis là c'est pour son train de vie et
son amante et chiite tué devait arriver
le quartier le plus huppé des états unis
ils ont une une escouade de dix gardes
du corps rien qu alors c'est ce qui est
plus qu il ya cent tonnes sans rythme de
viana américaine totalement et sont pris
qu'ils ont cramé les 30 bat il fut ma
aurait apparemment il flambe pourquoi je
suis pas personnellement dans les
comptes mais paraît qu'il reste pas
grand chose ouais mais c'est pour ça
qu'il faut c'est qu'ils ont signé un
contrat avec netflix de 60 millions de
dollars sans plus soixante huit mois
j'ai dû couper des vibrations parce
qu'avant ils paient rien pas les
transports mais là maintenant ils sont
obligés de tout payer mais c'est comme
vous allez vous retrouver dehors
c'est compliqué